uh welcome to session 23 of classic
metal class I've got here my good friend
and colleague Scott Chuli from the
Berkeley School of Music and also a
musician in his own right with a number
of albums more gigs and Studio
appearances than we could possibly ever
list and I'm going to be leaning heavily
on Scott for this one because this time
around we're talking about guitar solos
I am not a guitar player I am at best a
very mediocre basist Scott is an amazing
guitar player who teaches the topic and
so has a lot more to say about the you
know technical aspects of this and even
I think feel probably as well there's
there's something to like inhabiting a
song as a musician and learning solos
over and over and over again so I wanted
to kick it off there was something that
I saw today uh and I I shot it over to
Scott and he had an immediate reaction
which I'll allow him to replicate but
first i'm just going to read it so it's
in Sonic
perspectives and it's Kirk Hammet being
asked about some things and he says that
people are not going to remember a great
guitar solo I hate to say it to all your
readers out there they will remember a
great Melody they will remember a great
song and I'm not talking about musicians
mus musicians will remember a great
guitar solo but non-musicians who are
the majority of the effing listening
world are not going to
remember guitar solos so what do you
think about that
Scott uh a lot so first of
all um I guess his implied premise is
guitar solos are self-
serving uh and
indulgent um and well you just said Greg
that you know you don't consider you
consider yourself more of a listener
than a performer and yet you've written
a list of
solos um and you're going to be able to
articulate them in in in the discussion
today but you know I could do this all
day but I'll just what if everybody goes
to a Pink Floyd concert like you know or
or um right now it's uh what's his name
uh why am I forgetting his name he's on
the road and Dave kilminster is his
guitarist and let's say they do
comfortably numb and Dave Kil doesn't
play that solo from the record okay um
he's you know the that's part of the
song Another Brick in the Wall is part
of the song um there's so
many and like when I've done cover gigs
people are like you have to play the
Solo exactly like you know the album
because you know people are gonna you
know that's part of the song yeah and so
I kind of think it's it's it's a
ridiculous statement I don't know why he
would say that if that was taken out of
context
um I can't think of a reason
why unless he's unless he just thinks
that guitar solos are self-serving which
maybe he should it seems like he's
saying that musicians appreciate them
and actually remember them but
non-musicians it's just like slipping
past them and and notice he doesn't say
like non-musicians can't learn anything
about music he's saying they can
melodies they can get what if the guitar
solo is a Melody well that's it I mean
some guitar solos as we're going to talk
about are very melodic very lyrical
right so um in um a lot of rat where
Warren De Martini is the lead um you and
I have talked about this before he has
this very lyrical approach and I think
that the guitar solos are quite
memorable you know when you're um you
hear you hear like the Riff and and when
it gets to to the break of the song now
I've been listening to rats since ' 84
since I was a kid and so they're kind of
burned into my brain but I know you know
as soon as like that break comes in um
lay it down I know exactly what notes
Warren De Martini is gonna play and I
can whistle it or H everyone yeah and
and just back to the point I'm willing
to bet any Metallica fan that's a
non-musician can sing the Else Matters
solo but that's not Kirk Hammet that's
James Hetfield playing that solo it's
very melodic everybody knows that solo
so if I were to play just that solo yeah
people go that's nothing else matters so
um maybe I I don't know I mean like I
think he's even wrong
about you know if well do you think that
do you think that stems from his playing
style that he's judging solos as a whole
by them
but he's heard players he's heard music
as he that's true you
know and even before I played
guitar I knew guitar solos and and
certain guitar solos really excited me
before I picked up music at all and in
fact why I picked up the guitar right so
I was a non-musician that some people
were playing things that had an
emotional impact on on me the notes the
the execution
um came through really strong and that
attracted me to the instrument so I I
actually
can't I mean Kirk seems like a really
nice guy man but I don't know if I how I
could defend that statement in any way
so but I don't maybe other people think
differently you know if anybody else I
mean it's it's a good leadin I think for
conversation
um you know a lot the majority of fans
are going to be at best amateurs right
lovers of the genre and they may know
quite a lot about it but they're
probably not learning solos so as to
perform them you know yeah but they may
not might not be learning the songs to
perform them right right never mind none
of it they just enjoy it so yeah well
let's talk about one of the reasons for
bringing this up in the first place so
Scott and I were chatting one day about
solos having you know kind of a lyricism
to them being beautiful and integral to
songs as as compositions and that that
fits certain solos right we mentioned
Warren De Martini he's great for that
sort of thing in a different sense Tony
yomi is is great for that but you would
never confuse a Tony aomi Solo or riff
with uh you know something coming from
rat I think and uh I thought this would
be a great opportunity to to put Scott
you know more on on the stage or in the
dock and and ask him a lot of questions
about soloing and band because I don't
actually know that much about what goes
into it you know you just see the guy up
on stage or or in some cases the the
woman up on stage playing away and
you're like well that sounds awesome and
that looks cool but how the hell did
they do that I don't know you know um so
we could talk about what goes into it
but I I also you know thought you know
this is something really really integral
to heavy metal and I'm GNA bring in a
famous um sociologist of heavy metal
Dina Weinstein who I'm a big fan of so
in her book um Heavy Metal the music and
its culture which is a sociological
study she talks about the Sonic
Dimension and she you know first talks
about power and all that and then she
says the essential element of complexity
in the sound of heavy metal is the
guitar work which is embedded in an
increasingly elaborate electronic
technology that distorts and amplifies
the guitar is played as a lead
instrument a musical choice that
stresses its melodic as opposed to its
rhythmic
possibilities and then she goes on and
says the style of play owes much to
blues-based guitarists who transform the
urban blues guitar sound into rock
following the blues rock tradition heavy
metal guitarists are expected to
demonstrate technical proficiency this
emphasis on skill contrasts with the
punk code which emphasiz is the
Simplicity of playing the idea that hey
anybody can do this I just learned it
two weeks ago Punk stresses a leveling
between fans and performers heavy metal
with its guitar Heroes emphasizes
distance and then she says guitar solos
are an essential element of the heavy
metal code a solo is a part of the song
in which the guitarist does not compete
with the vocalist but may still be
backed by drums and bass it is a
rhetorical element of the code that
underscores the significance of the
guitar the solo was a feature of Blues
based Rock and here she talks about
according to Eric Clapton solos
originated with cream which sounds a
little self-serving with only about 30
minutes of original material they
stretched It Out by doing
improvisational solos the audiences
loved this Innovation and the solo
became a convention now that's complete
nonsense because there were plenty of
other people doing guitar solos but you
know it's one of those things where I
think she's right that it starts out
being used for one reason we got to fill
up some space uh look at what we can do
and then it turns into it's not the only
definitive thing in heavy metal I mean
baselines are incredibly important the
way people drum the type of singing and
she talks about all these as well as
like songwriting and riffs but um you
know I think you could legitimately ask
a question can you genuinely be a heavy
metal band unless you're in one of these
later genres without having solos in
your song Somewhere doesn't mean every
single song has to have a solo but it
does seem to be a really central part um
so I I I think it's worth delving into
and there's lots of questions that we
can raise because I don't think too many
people there's lots of lists out there
oh the 12 best guitar solos there's not
a lot of actual thinking about what goes
into solos what makes
great um Ken says um I agree with Scott
there's plenty of metal songs for which
a guitar solo is a fundamental part of
the track so that kind of goes to that
what Weinstein was saying that this is
an essential dimension of metal now
Scott you play in several different
genres yeah I mean you can say that
soloing as a guitarist for jazz is also
important right because there's that
Convention of like in a a lot of jazz
songs okay the basis is going to do a
solo there's a drum solo the guitarist
The Pianist who everybody gets a solo
right but that's not quite what's going
on with heavy metal songs I mean you do
have drum solos occasionally and bass
solos but well not um that's a really
good point to bring up
because Jazz the process is completely
different so um let's say we have a trio
and let's say and you could do it with
any song now real quick history the
reason there's Jazz standards you know
um uh and and and jazz players played on
pop tunes from the 40s or 50s and uh
Someday My Prince Will Come and the only
reason that those were tunes that jazz
players did is because when they got
together to hang out they all had heard
those songs they were kind of current
songs okay and so what happens is you
have the melody the form of the tune and
a set of core changes is the harmony now
as far if I'm with the trio and I'm
solo uh I have to have my ears wide open
because the drummer could completely
push me a different way Bas player could
uh even reharmonize something and my
ears have to catch up catch on to that
and go somewhere else so in jazz the
process of jazz is making one minutes of
one minute of Music in one minute's time
okay so it's always going to be
different and it's going to depend on
the people around you and how they are
playing at the moment where in rock the
the Rhythm Section might play the exact
same thing every night and you can
improvise over it but it's almost like a
backing track there's not there can be
interaction between the band and rock to
some degree but jazz is a completely
different art than say metal right so
yeah yeah so the so yeah it's going to
depend on the the moment um in jazz and
the people you play with now um I
actually just want to back up a second I
don't necessarily agree with
her uh Punk was basic and simple so it
reached and then metal was more
sophisticated so it distanced
itself
um I I I find that a little bit over
simplistic as well yeah because my my
response okay let's take early Maiden
the first more Punk more Punk than what
they and I I have a emotional response
to that I love it yeah but I also have a
emotional response to number the Beast
Steve Harris though is like super super
clear and I think Dave Murray also
echoed this that although they have Punk
energy um they what they didn't like
about Punk was the sloppiness and that
early Iron Maiden album it's tight you
know the everything fits together there
isn't that kind of Loosey Goosey Punk
feel in same with like motohead stuff
right motohead often gets talked about
as being Punk and metal at the same time
but when you look when you listen to the
composition of it right lemy is is doing
such tight complicated stuff on his his
base doing both the Baseline and rhythm
guitar essentially that um it's
interesting I saw an interview
recently well I think I may have brought
it into here yeah so this is from Fast
Eddy Clark Clark said um lemy was just
lemi Phil so the drummer and I had to
adapt to what we had to play which was
lem's bass we had to adapt to that kind
of sound because it's a very difficult
sound to play as a guitar player playing
a Rick and Bacher bass through a
marshall amp with all the trouble at
maximum and all the bass at minimum so
you can imagine there's not a lot of
bass as a lead guitarist going into a
solo it was like there was no net
underneath me and he also at some point
said and I I don't have it in here that
um playing with lemi forced him and Phil
Taylor to like up their game you know
they had to become better musicians by
playing with lemi and and you know so
there is this punkish Dimension to it
the energy the speed but the metal stuff
requires let's say proficiency and I
don't know that that distances us
from from the uh performance
I mean another thing that happens with
metal that she does talk about are the
performative things that the B the
audience do you know headbanging is one
of them but what's the most other common
thing playing air guitar right yeah and
people do that when when the guitarist
is
soloing and you know obviously they're
not playing the same notes as the
guitarist is they're just kind of like
moving their hands around in the air but
you know there it's it's mimetic they
are trying to identify with the person
who's up on stage with a spotlight on
them you know making faces while they
squeeze out notes from from their guitar
yeah I so from a Sonic point I think
what I'm getting at is take the Clash I
love The Clash um yeah but but take ACDC
take uh Adrian Smith um okay so there
there's kind of a test that I uh
uh I talk about with you know musicians
from other genres now um like let's take
a jazz somebody that plays straight up
jazz guitar with a big hollow body and
everything um you know I used to get in
fights with my friends younger that like
oh you know jazz players could could
learn Rock way faster than vice versa
and I said no because there's the G
chord trick right okay if I plug Les
Paul into a Marshall and crank it and I
have to and I hit a g- chord it's I mean
I have to hit it right just right loud
enough to push everything and like the
second somebody hears that G chord they
know it's rock and roll like Jimmy Paige
had it uh you know uh the punks had it
um but you know a lot of people that
don't use distortions or don't they're
not able to get that Sonic thing out of
the cord itself so that's why I'm saying
that maybe the the first although it was
more uh technical the first Maiden album
it it still had that in common with okay
when when when they hit an a chord it
was like that's rock and roll yeah yeah
you take somebody that's not rock and
roll they can't get the a chord to sound
like that and it sounds ridiculous but
it's it's very true like I do a I do a
test um and I did it at a show because I
have like a smaller 20 watt Plexi
Marshall Plexi with a you know kind of a
stack of a 212 cab so it's lower volume
but I'll either go out and bend a note
with some
vibr simple and if I could get the crowd
to start going bananas just from that
sound or hitting a G chord yeah that I
know I made them feel something just
sonically right yeah that's kind of my
like do I have my am I am I hear is my
sound there um and these are kind of
like little kind of tests I do to say
like you know uh okay now now you try it
you know like I want to say to some
people so what I mean uh by the the
comparison between the punks and metal
is I mean uh
metal has to have that same kind of
Sonic thing or we don't feel it here
yeah yeah Ian it doesn't have to sound
like Punk it does have that kind of
Sonic thing we react to because Rock and
in general is and as as you pointed out
in the past it doesn't have to be heavy
Distortion in order to accomplish that I
mean ACDC has that heaviness and
hardness with very just overdrive at
most right there's no Distortion the
guitars are very clean just a little bit
on it yeah and you know I was I was when
I was listening to some some old Iron
Maiden recently I was struck and you see
this also on on Old Judas Priest like
prior to say point of
entry maybe British steel um
not a lot of
distortion plenty of
overdrive things are crisp and clean but
heavy and you can you can and you can do
that with the solo too I mean you can
also have distortion on it and get that
kind of like Hollow sound to which is
very nice but um so Mark has an
interesting thing let's let's go off on
this I think this is going to be a h
session of many like going off in
different directions hot take I've never
been too into solos not that I don't
appreciate them to me the Riff
composition is more definitive of a song
as metal than it's solos though I guess
there are metal solos in the sense of a
specific repertoire of lick styles that
are common in metal soloing so I think
this is a great opportunity to put Scott
on the spot again and talk about the
difference between three different like
key elements of metal and also rock
songs the Riff the lick and the solo
because um these are I mean sometimes a
solo can be short enough that we might
say it's kind of a lick but if if it's
varying from Line to Line I think it's
more accurate to call it a solo and a
lick could be also called a filth
sometimes um especially if it's like not
a guitar but bass or something like that
so we've got riff which I I mean let's
start with that
so before I I ask got to try to Define
riff which may be rather difficult to do
um let's actually talk about this is is
the Riff for most songs more definitive
than the
solos I'm inclined to agree and say yeah
the Riff is more primary but the solo
still needs to be in there you know
think about um you know Tony Omi soloing
in Zero the Hero which is one of the
heaviest songs you can find out there
it's a very very heavy riff you could
say the same thing with another Black
Sabbath song
uh the devil cries you know where Dio is
is singing the Riff is just a monster
right that's part of what makes it metal
but it's not just the guitar it's the
bass following along with it but the
solos in that like I can I can remember
the solo Zero the Hero um and uh
probably not the devil cries but so what
do you think Scott is is the solo equal
to the Riff or is is the Riff more
important for a
song um well first of all I I think if I
understand Mark correctly what he means
is the solos is a repertoire is made of
up of a repertoire of licks right
somebody has a riff vocabulary and
pieces them together I Mark if I
understand you correctly somebody has a
vocabulary they put them together to
make a solo and that and we should we
should keep that in mind um uh
later but to answer your question
there's
no I mean
uh I'm thinking of this as all of it is
an ingredient to make a song I'm not
okay I mean yeah the Riff
is the Riff is important because if you
know just go to Guitar Center and you
know yeah kids will learn riffs you know
so um you know when they're playing Iron
Man they know you you know when they're
playing a whole lot of love you know
when they're playing and or black dog um
that you know somebody uh that's a
writing process a lot in metal like
somebody comes up with a
um somebody you know like a you know
come up with a riff all right what about
this you know NH what about this okay
that's cool where do we go from there
you know um so in metal riff riffs are
are very signature to the song as much
as the Melody you know um wait I was
going to say metal music that's some SS
that you won't often see in other well
yeah right um there there's a and that
changes over time um with the with the
solos the metal music The Lick Styles
although the ones I'm more attractive to
attracted to are the M Metal musicians
with good ears where they could play A
Melody and then embellish on that Melody
rather than okay than the solo comes up
and they're going to play a bunch of
Blues Licks that have nothing to do with
the song but just that they but it's
their time to like play yeah yeah and
those there's not there's no disrespect
to people that do it because sonically
could be pleasing but I I didn't choose
one solo that
had um that didn't have something to do
with the song that didn't that was like
everything I chose was kind of
unique uh and maybe some of it involves
licks like one of them like we talked
about before for is full of licks but
how it how it was basically used was
very kind of clever but um uh for the
most songs I would agree the Riff tends
to Define songs exactly guitars are
doing something um other than simply
providing sound for the singer iom
nickname for these devil yeah um but
even I mean even kiss of death that
opening that's a
riff you know like that's yeah yeah um
so that yeah I mean that's the Riff in
metal is usually where you start Smoke
on the Water come on I mean you know um
but then you build the song around it
right because if you don't and it's so
funny because uh that came up in the
guitar Department the other day that was
actually one of the first songs that I
learned on Banjo believe it or not
because it's so easy to do yeah and uh a
lot of people play it wrong but uh um
but you know
then one of I think we have this amazing
classical world-renowned Grammy
classical guitarist her name is Berto
Rosa and so that came up and I had my
guitar and I played the Riff she goes ah
but you know do you know the rest of it
I go I know the whole thing so I started
playing you know the verse and
everything and and she's like okay I you
know I just figured everybody just knew
the Riff and that's it and I'm like well
I'm a purple fan so yeah
yeah let's let's pause on one thing
though so um
lick and solo right um you could r No No
Lick and and and solo okay so I think
you could say that yeah there are a lot
of solos that are essentially put
together of licks so lick would be a
lower compositional level than solo
would be how do you is is it possible to
draw a line between them and say okay
this song only has licks it doesn't
actually have a solo and I'm thinking of
songs where things are quite melodic
like say Detroit Rock City right
that okay so that could be viewed as in
some respect a solo but we don't really
look at it so much as a solo even when
there's like the two guitar part playing
together on it um which is kind of a
cool cool element as
well um it's but it's not it's not licks
either it's it's essentially doing A
melodic work and it's not a riff um I
would call that a musical
interlude okay well that's interesting
because um guitar solos often get
defined in the um literature that's
attempting to be you know uh more let's
high brow as instrumental interludes
right and so interlude works there and
you know what is an interlude well it's
it's doing something different you're
not stopping the song and saying okay
we're g to now play a different song but
you are
shifting um the
emphasis to Something Different yeah I
mean the the the Detroit Rock City is an
amazing example it's it's a new section
of the tune but instead of vocals
playing the melody the guitars are
playing the melody so that's why I would
say it's a different section of the song
that's not a solo yeah I people would
probably say any anytime the guitar is
in the front it's a solo but um I don't
agree because like if you played Detroit
Rock say you and I had a band we played
Detroit Rock City and I just noodled
instead of that part people go whoa whoa
whoa wait you skip part of the song yeah
yeah the next part does this you know
whereas let's say after that then I just
ripped a solo then that would be more
acceptable although some people would
say you have to play what Ace played
because yeah Ace is classic and but like
you can't skip that part I can't just
say okay this is my solo spot it's not
you know it's a it's a it's a musical
interlude yeah so another one of the uh
things that I grabbed off the internet
uh is actually from ay and he's he said
these sort of things several different
times um and he he kind of he he really
likes Bruce Kulik Praises him to the sky
and then bashes yeah bashes Tommy theer
so he said br no kidding yeah so he said
when when uh Tommy theer uh gets up
there and does my solos he tries to play
him note for note but he doesn't have
the Swagger or the attitude Bruce used
to play my solos but he'd kind of make
him his own and he'd switch notes a
little and he had some originality
Tommy's just going through the motions
Bruce by far blows Tommy off the stage
it is what it is and then later on he
says I don't have anything bad to say
about Tommy you know it'd be one thing
if Tommy would have invented his own
character invented his own guitar solos
but unfortunately he's copying
everything I do note for note there's
not much leeway for anybody anybody to
say what he's doing is original I don't
know how I could handle that you know I
don't think I could step up to a
situation and be somebody else it's
almost like being a robot and he said
this in other interviews as well where
it's um the idea is that um a actually
at one point said you know I'm kind of
sloppy and that's why I play so good you
know because things things tomm is too
precise Tommy's like you know doing it
in a mechanical way which I don't I
don't actually see I've seen kiss in
concert a few times and um that
certainly isn't part of the live
performance you know you don't get the
idea that that Tommy theer's phoning it
in but it is interesting that he's he's
saying Bruce kulick was better because
he took my solos and then he' modify
them somewhat whereas you know Tommy
theer is doing them note for note that's
a great I'm so glad you brought that up
because I agree 100% And you know
Tommy's awesome and you know look yeah
let's face it um Paul and Gan are
calling the shots Tommy fair is that's
part of yeah they they actually asked
Tommy theer about this and he's like
well I'm not gonna touch that with a 10-
foot pole I'll just say this that I
don't get to like you said I don't get
to call the shots yeah but he's yeah so
he's an
employee yeah and when I'm in
employee whatever whoever's paying me I
it's my job to deliver the best I can I
do agree with the culic thing because
you know and it's true I mean I don't
think I mean Ace had his own feel I mean
I'm not comparing him to Eddie Van Halen
but in the sense that you nobody could
really copy Eddie because Eddie had his
own feel and Ace had his own Swagger and
when you hear that it's just like oh
that's right but then you hear somebody
else do it you're like yeah that's the
right lick but it's I'm not convinced
yeah yeah you know I so that's a really
I you know I'm I'm happy to hear that
you know uh Ace saw the distinction
although um Tommy the's great I think
there's a bit of professional jealousy
involved there though yeah maybe he's
that in thinking that that Tommy theer
is just mechanical and unoriginal and
stuff like that you know but Ace knows
better Ace knows that he's an employee
you know and maybe he's just going out
there to say there's only one me and you
know Ace is probably trying to say don't
be fooled everyone you want the real
thing it's right here you know yeah and
then that Bruce wasn't stepping on his
toes maybe that made him praise Bruce
wasn't putting on the makeup either no
no but and he was in the A and Bruce was
a completely different kind of guitarist
yeah um point for
later where I met uh so wait uh Mark did
we read this what I do enjoy but
probably because it's rare in metal
oh yeah okay you know um it's
interesting because so one of the things
we're going to talk about in just a bit
is Scott and I each challenged each
other to come up with our 10 favorite
solos we're not GNA say that they're the
absolute best or anything like that
because yeah I don't think we can use 10
we like exactly and then to talk about
why we we like them in particular and I
I went through quite a few deep purple
things and Richie Blackmore is
great um but it's interesting a lot of
the
soloing in Deep Purple at least well
well Richie Blackmore's around is him
and John Lord playing
together you know and you can say the
same thing with Mick box and UAH Heap
you know um it it doesn't work like that
so much with do where Claud Schnell is
adding flavor to it and Vivian Campbell
gets like just bust out you know um but
even like a good bit of rainbow um I
think there there's quite a bit of organ
or keyboard um involved in there and I
mean we could talk about great keyboard
solos you know but um even and Jan's
Johansson right okay you know but uh
that that's yeah that's sub subject for
another day I was already overwhelmed by
this and I think I went over my 10 I'm
not sure um this was one of the hardest
things to do really now why that's
that's an interesting thing to say
because I could go on for months about
great solos so so having to cap it at 10
is the challenge that's what I'm trying
that's why I'm trying to say to
everybody these are just 10 solos 10 of
the many solos I love and I'll just talk
about these 10 for right now um I'm not
into the so like people maybe you get
this what's your favorite song Oh
band I mean when I was younger because
I've actually been asked that question
about the favorite band in amas quite a
bit and I can say that when I was
younger like in my teens I could have
said Iron Maiden is my favorite band
right and then I could have said well
there's these other bands that I really
like as well there's probably like you
know 20 of them that I was listening to
fairly constantly some more than others
but Iron Maiden was at the The Pinacle
and it just hasn't been like that for me
for decades if you ask me I can very
reluctantly put together my top five or
top 10 or even top 20 but sometimes
bands kind of move in and and move out
you know yeah I mean that's to me any
kind of
um any well you know we were saying at
the very beginning before we started how
ridiculous those rolling stone top 100
guitarists and it's just a talking point
for everybody to get mad on the internet
Even Rick biato did a you didn't have
Alan holsworth in there you didn't have
you know and you know what's the
criteria you know and why are we getting
so I mean it it's it sells advertising
but there's no I do it does Bo like
award shows bother me you know in you
know Boston Music Awards here it's you
know well you know it's not let's just
say none of this stuff is it's a racket
right it's a racket it's not a mocracy
um and I don't you know unfortunately I
don't know if a lot of people see that
so it's like you know it's funny like
you'll get like Boston's best jazz act
and it'll be someone that's not really
Jazz and a band that's not really good
but then you have Legends like Jerry
bergonzi here and and um Joe laano and
like people that are like you know play
people that play with Miles Davis that
have stuff out that aren't even being
considered it's like yeah so Ken Ken ask
a like the100 question here can there
even be objective criteria for picking a
best solo no so I would say no I think
we can have objective criteria for what
sucks where we can say like um this is
no good because XYZ and it could also be
like not a about um the solo itself but
about the
backing song at the time you know we
were listening to this 80s station and a
Survivor song came on and I don't even
remember what it was but it wasn't ey of
the Tiger but it sounded like they were
trying to redo ey of the tiger basically
just not as good really and yeah and and
um you know it was a plotting boring
bass trck boring riff and then there was
like a solo part and I I because I was
thinking about our solo discussion and I
was like this is a decent solo but the
whole song sucks and the solo sucks
because of it because the the backing
stuff is just so formulaic you know it's
not interesting which era do you know I
think it I think it was from the same
era as I of the tiger because it sounded
similar in in other Sonic respects you
know um and it was something that got
some AirPlay but it just wasn't as good
you know I think it Andy said it showed
up in some some other Rocky soundtrack
so oh it was like a it was like a
montage uh Ready song basically and for
montages that can work right you don't
want the music to distract you from the
film that's Happ Burning Heart maybe I I
I don't know I love that song
yeah that but that's what a different
singer that's what Jimmy James no I I
don't think it was a different singer so
I I don't know what song it was but it
was it was just kind of okay mediocre
you know and and I I think we can say
that about some car solos you know like
somebody comes in and you're like Ah
that's just not very good and you could
say well why not it sounds sounds tired
it's um you know if they are hitting
interesting combinations of notes it
sounds like it's by accident not because
they actually meant to do that you know
right right and that's a point does it
have
intention yeah now I mean you teach
guitar so I'm assuming assuming that
some of your students are doing solos in
your class are there any objective
criteria that you can you can apply to
them and say okay your solo is not good
here's
why I usually don't do that I
usually I usually try to teach intention
and what intention is is making your
ears better for example a starting point
could be put put your first finger on
any note on the guitar so they will and
I say play that note and I'll say now
take your time don't play it in time but
don't play it in time play happy
birthday without making a mistake um but
take your time to think where that next
note is so if you could you know what
happy birthday sounds like if you have
the intention to play it on your
instrument and you can't do it then you
your ears have to get better like you
know if if if I were to sing a student
something play this and they can't find
it that's the first thing we need to
address is their ears right okay and
then um you know because really all of
this is subjective some people think
Kirk Hammet is amazing you know um I
think Kirk Hammet is a is a nice guy uh
I don't I've never been a fan of his
guitar playing um none of it you know
yeah well I like the early stuff when
they sounded like pissed off
18-year-olds I did I did think that when
he played Reckless solos and they made
no sense it did have kind of a screaming
it should have sounded like that yeah
yeah but um but you know I've I've never
been a Kirk hamut fan but like you know
so many people are and so I can't you
know it's not up to me who sucks you
know it's not up to me but you know I
could describe like you did like you did
a really good job of saying why this you
know Frankie sullin blew it on a some
solo and uh and yeah I mean as long as
well this is what this whole session is
about is the the anybody can say they
like something can they articulate it
what's the criter right right and why do
you think that and I think that becomes
really important and I try to teach my
students that in what do you like you
know oh I love this this solo what is it
about you like that that you like it
it's just awesome you know like okay
we're gonna work we're gonna work on
that because you know being aware
of you know your what you like and and
find interesting could be just
educational to how you put stuff yeah I
mean I enjoy watching uh interviews with
musicians mostly um guitarists and
basist but sometimes with with singers
like Dio where he's you know I mean he
he knows all the
instruments where they talk about what
they're doing and and why they were
doing it so for example JK Lee has some
videos where he's going he's leading you
through the Riff for Bark at the Moon
which a lot of people get wrong yeah and
then he's like and here's why you got to
do it this way and here's why this has
to be in here to produce this effect
otherwise you're going to get this or
you know recently I was listening
somebody we're going to talk about in a
bit fast Eddy Clark talking about what
what they were doing in motohead and why
he was playing the way he was there and
then what it was like in fast way uh
where he had like a traditional basist
with Pete wayy uh at least for a little
while and then he got replaced um but
you know he had a four-piece set with
with that um so it's you know there
you're right there is a lot of
subjectivity to it but being able to
articulate and here's so I'm going to go
into a very different direction it
reminds me of something that's found in
Emmanuel kant's third critique the
critique of judgment where he is very
interested in
Aesthetics and one of the things things
that was really puzzling a lot of people
in the 18th century was okay it seems
like we can have rules for all sorts of
things like engineering and morals and
all of that is it really the case that
we can't dispute matters of taste and
Kant says well yes and no um you when it
comes to uh and this is actually gon to
get to Mark's question about teleology
in in just a minute um when it comes to
artistic or even other things like
flowers things that we find beautiful or
things that we find
Sublime um we make judgments about them
and we make them as if they are binding
upon everybody but they're not because
they are coming from a subjective basis
but we present them as if they were
objective even though they aren't and
that's why we can get into arguments
about them and then we can bring up
reasons reasons on this side reasons on
this side but those reasons although
feeling like they're compelling they
aren't binding on everybody but when you
actually produce a really
great uh piece of art it has kind of an
internal logic to it which you can look
back retroactively and say aha this is
going this way because of this and this
comes together with this and that leads
to this effect over here but you
couldn't have addicted it you can't you
can't do great art or great music sort
of like in a cookie cutter I just push
this button and this happens kind of way
you have to work through it and and
probably do a lot of iterations and and
try it out and then you produce it and
then people are like holy crap look at
this you know and they you've you've got
a good song now Mark asks
um what is the end the purpose of a good
solo other than invoking emotion which
is clearly one of the things that they
do what is it supposed to do as a solo
and in the overall song as a composition
and so you know it's it's not just
decoration right uh uh guitar solo is
integral to metal songs but and you
could have some songs like you know Van
Halen's Eruption right where it's just
the guitar soloing by itself but you
don't want to have too much of that you
know and you don't want a guitar solo to
go on too long and just be an excuse for
you know standing up on stage and and uh
engaging in kind of a masturbatory you
know showoff kind of thing this is this
is where Zach wild turned a lot of
people off with a Black Label Society
doing like you know five minute solos
you know of just Wily Wily
Wily by the way Zack Zach wild is is an
unbelievably great guitar player
but it's his attitude where it's like
the pinch harmonics and as fast as you
can but you listen to like the first
album his his tone his
vibr everything is just so good it's his
attitude before I move
on yeah so I was gonna say um a guitar
solo is an opportunity to stand out and
do something on your
own but it's got to fit in to what's
that you mean
unaccompanied well no you could have the
bass and the drums and and other guitar
behind you you could even have like the
singer you know like every once in a
while doing those kind of interjections
like oh baby you know or something like
that like David Lee Roth couldn't resist
doing stuff like that right but um it's
got to fit the song if it doesn't fit
the song and this is something you
talked about earlier but if if if it's
just virtuosity for its own sake then
people are like ah this this doesn't
doesn't really make sense with the song
it's it's cool to watch the Guitar Hero
up there but you know like so imagine if
Richie Blackmore and Smoke on the Water
said okay I'm doing a 10-minute Solo in
the middle of this you'd be like well I
knew the guy was a jerk already to his
bandmates but this is over the top
unless unless he could play interesting
stuff for 10 minutes but that's not the
case with most
musicians yeah and before we move on
yeah this is just for me and I think
every what was the C you you
cited it's called the critique of
judgment or the third critique and it's
one of his most puzzling works you know
and and I think in part because he's
tackling topics that um are kind of
messy like well how is it that we can
actually have disputes about things that
seem to be purely subjective and it not
just be feelings right how can we aduce
reasons for for what we think or
articulate reasons you know we're gonna
have to discuss that another time
because great that you brought it up
because I I did you know I was going to
ask hey Greg was there a work that has
been done by a thinker that has kind of
discussed this kind of you know I know
we're talking about you know yeah metal
I mean I I will say that Kant isn't
discussing music there um doesn't have
to be music but yeah I mean there are
later thinkers who do talk about music
much more including one who identified
himself as a consun that's Arthur
schopenhauer you know um and I I think
that he's right that there's some things
that you can do through music that you
can't do through say um plastic Arts
like painting and
sculpture you know sorry I didn't mean
to interrupt but like no no no because
you said it and I'm like oh I wow that I
gotta take see I need to take notes
let's let's come back to this question
though is is there I don't know that
there is a single identifiable purpose
to a guitar solo no um are there like a
basket of them like some could be just
to like fill up time and space like you
know Eric lapt talking about cream had
30 minutes worth of set that they needed
to stretch out to an hour right I mean
you kind of feel like jam bands do that
too right um in some respects um that's
a good that's a really good point
because speaking of Survivor I saw them
years ago and Jimmy Jameson you know he
came in in 8 for on that Vital Signs
album and every song was a hit this is
years after I had the tiger when the
other guy left
and I mean it's just there were so many
hits and Jimmy Jameson is like you know
Steve Perry it's like those two were
like the hot like rock singers to me but
there was a tune where they just did a
vamp and the guitar player played a
15minute solo over it and I'm thinking
that's four songs yeah and the thing
about Frankie Sullivan is he's cool but
he ran out of ideas in the first 20
seconds like it's not like it's not like
he could take us on a 15-minute joury
Journey you know and I I wouldn't be
able to just jam on something for 10
minutes I'd get sick of myself like the
second my ideas start to run out I'll
wrap it up so okay it's really in
interesting um from the the guitarists
themselves now back to the question is
um it doesn't have to be a a list of you
know does it make this checklist I like
a lot of the
stuff I chose there's going to be
different reasons why they work yeah you
know they're not all G to be like I'm
not gonna have the same answer oh what
do what do you think about this Marx as
the good soloist performs with
moderation even when they're like you
know going all out
amadas yeah too many notes which on you
want me to take
out yeah I mean but that that does go to
that issue of solos that are that are
too long or too self-indulgent that
could have that could have been another
song with the whole band you know
playing involved in it I mean I think
let's see the good Souls performs in
moderation well not always um like one
of my solos is not moderation at all but
it's a good kick in the ass and there is
intention but we'll get to that I
mean yeah there's not I
can't no because for anything I I would
say there's going to be a solo exist
that proves me wrong that's a yeah an
exception to it yeah I guess that's a
good thing to say yeah yeah go uh what
else do we have can a solo ever suit
plurality of
taste so I think the answer to that is
yes I mean because a solo can have
different points to it or different
purposes to it
um now I don't think that you're going
to find a solo in any of this where like
everybody particularly people who are
are you know competent more competent
judge are going to say yeah we we
completely agree there's unan unanimity
about this being a wonderful solo I
think you can always find just like
anything else you can find something to
say ah there's there's something missing
there's something too much there's
something that that detracts but um I
don't know maybe we could say
that
um there's rough consensus
on at least in the metal community on
some um songs some some
musicians as being really good in that
respect yeah well you know this this
raises a really interesting question
that like with all this stuff that we're
talking about and being able to express
yourself yeah yeah so this is actually
just for me and I'm curious to hear
everyone's take on this
um this show is built around two people
that have an area of expertise right you
know Greg um I've learned a lot from
Greg but but Greg raises very
interesting points for me to kind of
answer I have the years as a
professional musician and different you
know but when it comes to my profession
I'm and there might be other professions
like this uh where some people say well
you're not any more of an expert than a
Layman like you're you're you just have
an opinion and music is man and you
can't you can't tell me what's good
because you know so I mean we actually
get something like that in
philosophy where Ordinary People off the
street will be like well we're all
philos philosophers man we all have
ideas about stuff and you're like okay
yeah I mean we can all bake too you know
I mean some people can like get a cake
mix and put the eggs and oil in and put
it in a pan and stuff like that that
doesn't mean I'm a chef you know that's
a great
analogy but I know I've been told that
before where uh in the music world
there's there's people that say if you
know what you're doing you're not
creative um it's and we've talked about
this before I think that's totally wrong
I and when I say totally wrong I'm not
being hyperbolic I'm not I'm not just
like saying something just to like get a
rise I I do think that's that's
completely wrong that you know without
technique without actual developed body
of knowledge and practice and stuff like
that whether it's um uh drawing
music writing um you're just not the
stuff that you're going to produce will
be music but it's going to be crap music
you know it's just I mean it's like
playing happy birthday you know I mean
anybody can play Happy Birthday um right
but you know playing happy birthday and
then adding in a Harmony suddenly it
starts to get difficult you know right
yeah and I get that from people it's
kind of um and you know I have a whole
speech about it but you know uh well if
I learn music theory it's going to you
know creativity well no and I always say
if you're creative no matter how what's
in your toolbox you'll be creative
whether there's three things in there
you you'll be fine if you have more
things in there you have more things to
work with to be creative with I don't
know how it I don't know where that but
like there is this kind of thing where
yeah like you know the uh going back to
the prince solo you know we talked about
before you know Prince did that uh uh
that Beatles song and it was a good My
Guitar Gently Weeps men it was a good
solo but you know all of a sudden
everybody's like this is the greatest
guitarist who knew he was the best this
is the best solo I've ever heard and
then you know I'm like they would show
me I go well I think you're reacting
because he's Prince and he looks super
cool and it's a good solo yeah but but
it's not and you know well you're just
you know never mind you you don't you
know and uh so it's really interesting
about taking the
criteria and um I do remember you saying
that about philosophy like you know I
have thoughts too yeah but you have more
well informed
thoughts yeah and it it's sort of like
um people coming in and sort of the
analogy here is people so I I'll use
stoicism because this comes up all the
time people are like they'll they'll
post a problem or a question in in a
online group and you're like well that's
discussed by Sena in this thing here
there's a resolution to that and then
somebody will be like man I just
practice stoicism I don't actually like
to study those texts because that
stifles my you know my living and
creativity and you're like well guess
what that's actually talked about in the
stoic
texts epic tetus you know not quite
2,000 years ago but pretty close had
people who'd to him and they'd be like
ah man I don't need to study logic I
just want to like live my life and do
ethics you know and ethics is about how
to live and then he's like all right go
see how that works for you and then as
soon as somebody tricks you because you
couldn't actually follow an argument uh
and you start doing something stupid and
incurring some consequences come back
and we can study logic because then
you'll be in the proper frame of mind
for it but this this whole like I don't
need to like study I don't need to learn
I don't need to practice all of that's
going to like hold me back from my I
think a lot of these people like feel
like they have an innate creativity and
the notion of like genius or stuff like
that has been very damaging in that
respect right I mean it's clear that
some people have temperaments that are
different than other people and some
people have talents you know I'll just
give you one prime example from my uh
family so my
great-grandfather uh was called Pepe by
everybody and that's just sort of French
Canadian for her Grandpa and he put
together a band of kids during the Great
Depression and took them on a tour and
they traveled all the way out to the
Rocky Mountains from Rhode Island and he
play he could play every single
instrument he got a bunch of instruments
together and then he just assigned them
to kids so like my grandpa played the
Cornet my uncle yubert played the trom
bod and you didn't choose what
instrument you got and pepe taught you
how to play the instrument and did all
the
orchestration never had a lesson in his
life was just you know what we would
call a musical genius and now some of
that would come from you know something
you know that that's innate but that
sort of thing is pretty rare right and
pepe did not say oh I better not have
any lessons or read any books because
that's going to get in the way no if he
had the chance to actually like learn
something from somebody who actually
knew something he would grab that
opportunity it just happened that he was
a pretty DIY guy because he was poor as
dirt and he worked with other people who
were poor as dirt who couldn't go to a
conserv or you know get music lessons or
stuff like that now I think a lot of
people in our present Society are like
you know I've got this hidden talent in
me I just gotta express it you probably
have students who come to you like that
um fortunately we don't get a lot of
people like that in philosophy you know
coming to take classes with us who are
like I'm a great philosopher I just need
to like learn a few things um so you
know getting them to understand that no
no learning things learning what other
people have done learning what they
think learning what they think works and
doesn't work that's not going to stifle
you that's actually going to open doors
for you and allow you to progress you
know yeah I think the big thing is
students will come in and they'll be the
hometown hero and they'll have some
licks and they can play they could play
some fast solos and they kind of think
they're there and then well they can't
read yeah like you know well Eddie Van
Halen couldn't read Eddie Van Halen that
wasn't part of his
journey and then okay well you can
improvise if we're in key now I'm going
to write these three chords what CHT is
that well you better figure it out
because you need to improvise on it
right now and then you know after a few
seme ERS when they're not doing this
stuff I'll go I'll put reading in front
of them and I'll go okay you need to
read that I can't oh too bad because
there's this gig tonight that pays 700
bucks that I can't make yeah so you know
with Eddie Van Halen So this is
something I really want to ask you about
um in terms of musical
development so Eddie Van Halen and the
you know people that he was connected
with um in the band early on they had
this very long difficult apprenti ship
they learned over a hundred different
cover tunes oh yeah and they played them
night after night after night after
night and they practiced you know hours
and hours a day and um you know you're
you're going to learn other people's
solos as part of those those cover tunes
and figure out how to make them your own
right and you could say oh well that's
not being original well it's sort of
like you know um walking in somebody
else's shoes you're going to learn a lot
of things along the way that you
wouldn't have learned just doing it
entirely on your own and then um you
know once he starts to develop his own
stuff um it's not as if he just like got
up there and noodled and like the inner
creativity came out I mean he was
practicing his stuff hours and hours a
day right so you
know I guess part of so there's your
student
but even like great musicians they're
still learning from each other right we
can talk about somebody like
um you know Dave Murray um influencing
other guitarists okay younger guitarists
right and if you want to be able to play
like Dave Murray plays you're you're
never gonna be Dave Murray any more than
you're gonna be Ace Freely um but you
can follow their solos and what is it
that you actually learned I I mean I'll
ask you I I'll condense it to this
because you're somebody who has learned
a lot of other people's solos um what
were you actually learning when you were
playing along with their solos and like
listening to them and thinking about
them not just making your fingers move
in the right ways what were you getting
out of it this is the a great question
um early on it was it was I knew the
pentatonic scale because I was taking
lessons and I kind of knew the minor
scale so I recognize when I would learn
solo Rock solos kind of you know what
was going on in them now here's the
thing um I do a lot of stuff that's uh
within a rock solo that takes the ear in
a different direction and people go well
what's that and I'll say well I bought a
Herby Hancock record and I transcribed
all of it I wrote it all out it took you
know a few weeks and I matched all the
solos
but because I have a foundation in
theory and understand Triads SS I
understand Harmony I could say this is a
G7 chord and he was playing this
arpeggio over it and that would mean
this is going on so because I have a
solid foundation in being able to look
at a transcription and and say wow well
I didn't know you could do that but he's
doing this and I guess that makes sense
because it comes from this pitch set
yeah yeah essentially took lessons from
her Hancock because it's all there but
if I didn't know what I was doing I
would just be copying the notes and
maybe I I get a technical exercise out
of it but then I could say wow he took
this pentatonic scale and added a flat
nine for this chord I'm going to do that
and then I'm going to you know do it in
in my own way so um nobody's you know
this goes back to you know everybody
that has that badge of honor I'm
self-taught Well everybody's everybody's
self-taught I could sit here and tell
you Theory all day and it's up to you to
process it and make something happen
with it because the only way you really
self-taught is if you were born in a
bubble and you never heard music and you
invented it but people that claim
they're self-taught most of them you
know copied Jimmy pagee or copied and
they have those licks at that but I mean
you would have to grow up in a complete
vacuum and then how the hell would you
even know that you want to play rock and
roll yeah well he give you an instrument
and now you're selftaught but but you
know um I don't understand you know if
you're you're learning from YouTube
would it matter if the person was next
to you yeah or if they're on YouTube
it's you know and I I don't quite
understand the badge of honor because
you know I run into people all the well
how do you make a living as a musician I
have a set of skills I could do rock and
roll and not think of anything and have
fun I could do my own music I could do
whatever I want but when it comes to
paying the bills I have a set of skills
that makes me employable especially this
day and age
yeah you know so you know that's when
people start to realize like ah you know
and at least when I started out there
was so many gigs I was making a lot of
money for a 21y old they don't really
exist as much anymore yeah with the
skills you can earn a lot but uh so Ken
has something interesting here and I and
this is gonna lead into uh something
that Richie Blackmore said um being good
at guitar solos requires knowledge of
Music skill and practice to maintain
skill level I would suggest that playing
a musical instrument is very much a
perishable skill I'd imagine the same
could be said of implementing philosophy
in life and I'd say yeah um you you do
always have to like practice and people
who stop
practicing they they go backwards now I
want to offer an opposite to this Richie
Blackmore was asked in in an interview
are there solos you played with deep
purple that stand out in your mind and
he says the solo and Highway way star
was worked out it's just arpeggios based
on Bach on Machine Head as a whole in
fact there's some good stuff the guitar
solo on pictures of home was good but
when I hear that compared to what I'm
doing now there's a big difference to me
it's much better now I didn't have the
control then I do now so we think about
like his classic period deep purple
rainbow and he's saying h i was good not
as good as I am now I've I've developed
more control
he does also say I think the solo on
Gates of Babylon on Rainbow's long live
rock and roll is the best solo I've ever
done it's the best because it's the most
intricate solo but it's not clinical it
was spontaneous it wasn't 24 bars of
just playing on E there's weird chords
involved that I could go back to my old
way of playing which is to have the
chords in front of me and play the solo
whereas now every time I go into the
studio to play I know exactly what the
song consists of right so a couple
different things there one is like
Blackmore himself is like yeah I still
needed to improve you know I was a
Guitar Hero back then top of the world
but you can still get better which is
kind of a cool idea um kind of
inspirational and I don't think you know
a lot of people talk about Richie
Blackmore being
inspiring I mean PL let's just say that
yes exactly as a as a person um but then
also this idea of like Gates of Babylon
why was the solo so good
because he had to work around weird
courts rather than just playing a you
know typical straight ahead you know
kind of heavy metal riff or like say in
one position or one scale or yeah yeah
so I mean what do you think of those two
things well there's a really good point
about people that stop practicing so oh
people there there's different TP types
like let's
take
[Music]
um a legendary band like uh and or a
guitarist and they sound the same now
that they did 30 years ago but that
probably means that they you know
stopped really working on stuff and then
just by playing they're maintaining it
right yeah and um for me um as far as
like the technique I need I'm one of
those people that um
I do need
to I feel like I need to maintain my
technique because I have a couple
friends in town that never play their
guitar but have unbelievable technique
and they go you don't need to practice
it's just there but you know I have a
joke I'm like man I lose my chops in a
four bar rest you know so but um I'm
also practicing new Concepts and and
um new things that I can't do you know
and I'm always working on my ears you
know ears are fundamental but they can
always get better believe it or not I
still work on my site reading but I
really work on how I approach things uh
putting notes together as sounds not
calling them chords and I'm I keep
reaching for new sounds but um
so I you know I'm always reaching to
sound better but there's some people
that they stop at some point and they're
great they're amazing and they just
maintain it by playing which there
nothing wrong with I mean you know once
somebody's just developed their sound
and style I mean there is there is a
certain good to being able to just keep
doing a good job at what you've you've
learned to do right
um and that could that could be in music
that could be in artwork that could be
in cooking you know sometimes you want
meatloaf it doesn't have to be like
deconstructed or have have you know new
spices in it or something like that we
call that comfort food right and maybe
there's comfort music um like when
people go people go to see Ario
Speedwagon they're not expecting to hear
anything new you you know oh you know
that's so and yeah that's that's kind of
like last week and you know I was a huge
Speedwagon fan in in in high school I
was a huge fan of a lot of people yeah
when I used to see them in the 80s they
used to do most of the new album they
had a few that they always did anyways
but you
know now um you know they have you know
a lot of these bands have this is off
subject but they have live hits in other
words the songs were never hits on the
radio but they're always part of their
set like like Ario does like keep
pushing every show but that was never a
hit yeah but it has every show I was
just laughing because with bands like
Aaron Maiden who couldn't get airpl to
save their life for a long time
basically every every hit had to be a um
concert hit because the anent
Mariner yeah you're not gonna hear rhyme
of the Ancient Mariner on too many radio
stations because it's you know what 14
minutes long so or is it 12 minutes long
I mean it's very long so yeah I mean
they will play other crazy long songs
like inagata deita or um on the classic
that's right yeah or uh um
Hocus Pocus is pro call Harum you know
but what about um what about the live
version with the three minute rant of
must have got lost uh Jay gues Band you
remember when they used to play the the
five minute rant at the beginning reputa
reputa the bua I don't know it's like
that was maybe because they were a
Boston band but it was like I must have
got lost and it was like the intro alone
was like four or five minutes of like
Peter Wolf just giving G this whole you
know okay yeah but yeah so that you
know I think now they probably that off
I think we we have to get to um
something that we were GNA talk about
namely um and we're not gonna get
through all of them but some of the
solos that we we think are particularly
stand out a as great and what's so good
about them so do you want to pick one of
yours first okay and this is in no
specific order uh the first one I'll say
is uh Dio's last in line with Vivan
Campbell now this was hard because
there's a bunch of Vivian solos I really
liked yeah um the thing I really like
about I always loved about viven um I
almost chose uh
anyways um in the last in line
solo it has a very interesting you know
uh intro
line you know and that just alone is
kind of setting up this kind of dark
Moody thing yeah and something and
something that I
loved and he was younger right he was
like 17 18 years old the thing that I
always loved is there's this part where
he hangs on these no
like yeah and back then that took a lot
of guts but he doesn't he doesn't feel
the need to like fill up the Sonic space
with like lots of going up and down so
like that but emotionally that hit me
the most that was kind of like this
lonely kind of dark yeah and then the
drums kick in and he
starts and then that kind of rhythmic
thing and then he starts going with some
of the Chuck berix and then he does like
start cooking at the end but um it's you
know it's in the end gets exciting and
you know he does show his technique
there but
I always just was floored when he would
play solos he would be
fine leaving these notes hanging for you
know two beats and and Holy Diver which
is one that I picked yeah that's the one
I I mean I that the the very early part
of the solo is over not exactly sure how
to describe it technically but it's that
dant you know so one of the things that
was really cool about do's um
compositions and this is as a whole you
know like the riffs is that there's
space in there there's there's a
willingness to like there's a melodic
line that's carrying through and it can
have like a gap in there here and there
um you know Bob daisley was good with
that on on Basse too with with Aussie's
early stuff too um and um the the solo
is kind of you know like you were saying
it's it's uh it's not that the Solo's
slow but it's deliberate at the start
and then it starts getting into more
like going through arpeggios and stuff
like that and by the end of the solo
it's soaring you know so there's I guess
you'd call that Dynamic aspects right
yeah although that was that's the one I
was going to pick first okay but he it
he does those um it's a technical term
but quarter note
triplets
yeah wow you where did you hear that in
solos it's just kind of like he's like
pulling you back and uh he's not in a
rush and um and that's the stuff even
when I was younger when you know a young
teenage young teenager it was like kind
of like fast fast fast but um yeah
always respond to the fast fast fast I
just thought
viven I
also I also think that um you know
sometimes you think you have people have
a lot of Courage doing that and I I'm
suspecting that Ronnie James Doo
was um really supportive of that stuff
and you know made it okay because I know
Ro Rowan Robertson who was on lock up
the Wolves said that Dio was amazing to
work with on lock up the wolves and that
he was so encouraging and he was such a
gave D great Direction I'm assuming that
Ronnie had to do with no play that I
like that you know where at that time
it's like God I'm be on this the
greatest singer album and everybody's
going to judge me that I'm not good
enough you know well I read something
really interesting that supports that um
originally Jakey Lee was supposed to be
the lead the the guitarist for Di's solo
act and it makes sense because Dio was
managing Ru cut at the time uh um JK Lee
was from the LA scene you know he'd been
in um ozy's uh uh band well no he's in
Aussie's band afterwards uh he went over
to Aussie's band but he but he'd been in
Rat and and rough cut and stuff like
that and when Dio brought him in he's
like you've got to play harder more
straightforward less complicated riffs
that's what I want you to do and he and
Jakey Lee couldn't see eye to eye on
that and so it's not it's not going to
be like you you know think about Bark at
the Moon right it's it's a very cool
riff it's like iconic days it wouldn't
fit into a do song Campbell was the
right guy at the time for that sort of
thing and I think it's reflected in his
soloing you know yeah and now you know
since he's been in De leopard he has no
problem playing half the solos that Phil
Colin plays you know he um
he's you know from what I've heard uh I
haven't met him but what I what I've
heard he's like the sweetest guy you
ever want to know so I think from the
beginning you know he might have had ego
go out of uh out of it but um but like
he he had chops man you like when he
wanted to go he went but it's just yeah
he didn't um he really you know those
those long notes always struck me and so
I just I was going to do that one but I
chose last in line because I kind of
like how the band kind of builds it up
together and oh yeah it's amazing you he
the commas and the periods at the end of
sentences when making his statements and
yeah but I and this is we talked about
this um in a previous session you know
when people are asked like what's the
best do album if we put aside the
rainbow and and Black Sabbath stuff
people usually are going to pick um Holy
Diver I think last in line is actually
Holy Diver is an amazing album uh last
in line is even better I think and I
think part of that can be attributed to
the people who are playing on it you
know and you know I love those albums so
much although yeah the Mr unpopular
opinion I love Sacred Heart yeah I mean
the there there isn't a bad do album
yeah rock and roll children um king of
rock and roll I mean that album got the
most spins from me I love them all but
yeah let's talk about so we've got a
couple others where you and I both pick
the same band but I think we have
somewhat so let let's look at the
Scorpions one because there we got two
two different guitarists right and one
of them is not the one that you'd expect
so you picked um off a Virgin Killer
catcher train which I I love all that
ear early uliv Von Roth or joh John Roth
stuff um he he's just an amazing
guitarist but he does have a very
different feel than Matias jobs who I I
describe as a little bit more um
Straight Ahead as a guitarist than um I
mean Von r John Roth was like all over
the map just I mean he you could tell
that he was somebody that he had
complete fluidity with his instrument
and I picked um animal magnetism the
title track animal magnetism because
it's got that you know
D Riff to it right and then there's that
soloing over it that's um it's kind of
unconventional it's
that you know kind of um just playing
over that that riff and never doing
anything really spectacular but it makes
the song so so heavy that's Rudolph
shner not I didn't knows yeah I mean I
had to look it up on the Wikipedia I was
like I just want to make sure that
that's because I I was confusing it with
um love Drive where Michael shner had
played on on a few of the tracks right
and I was like I better make sure it's
not Michael shner no it's Rudolph shner
who rarely solos at all but on that one
he was dead on and Rudolph Shanker is is
is content to sit back and be the band
leader and songwriter and make
everything work um most of the
time but on that one he he really
knocked it out of the park you know yeah
oh yeah I did not
know well see I learned I learned
something and I kind of did the same
thing like unless I knew for sure I kind
of checked things out so well you have
to I think right especially if they've
changed guitarists so tell us about uh
catcher train and why you picked that
one I mean there's so many great uh ulie
John Roth solos yes why that one in
particular um there's a lot of rhythmic
variation in his Solo in that one and
just the way he attacks the notes I like
his sound like how he picks um the sound
he gets out of his fingers but the
rhythmic variation and on that one
it fits the song but you you know I I
don't know the answer to if he wrote it
or improvised it but it sounds if you
write something it should sound
improvised if it's really written well
and to me that sounded like he was
stretching for something and they caught
it on tape oh wow and like okay that's a
great description yeah and maybe I'm
wrong but like you know it's just you
know I always found him such a creative
player like um we we were all talking
about licks before someone that's like I
don't want to fall into that I want to
discover something and I've always liked
him as a player and what what I did what
I what I told um Greg at the beginning
of this is I actually went back to some
albums I hadn't listened to in over 20
years and I went back to that album and
uh and then I was like I remember this
and I was like gez this solo is just and
I actually listen to it a lot I'm like
you know this is like you think of
period too you know and as as always say
it's like what was that
75 76 Virgin Killer uh I want to say
70 77 maybe so you know I always say you
know just as far as the invention of the
rock band would be February 9th 1964
when the Beatles were on Ed Sullivan
that's when everybody wanted to be in a
band I'm not saying that's where Rock
and Roll started I'm just saying that's
where the concept of everybody wanted to
be in a band okay yeah and so you I mean
you have to think at the time you know
uh you know we're like 12 years after
that or something and you know for
somebody to kind
of have that sound have that time
variation and the
creativity and if it wasn't it sounded
like you know he was in the studio and
reached for something and then they
caught it that's that's what I really
like about it and it's not like one of
those he wasn't self-indulgent it it fit
the tune but it was just I like things
that surprise my ears like you know
sometimes you could tell what he's he's
good about that you know yeah and I like
that in compositions too where there's
like a new section or a new chord that
perks my ear up going oh that's new and
I like that in guitarist where they
they're like here you go you like you
know oh you know we're somewhere else
I'm like oh I didn't expect that where
are we going now like and it becomes
kind of an adventure within the
structure of the song so that's why I
picked that one yeah let's let's pick
one that um Ken also mentions the same
band so Iron Maiden you and I both
picked Iron Maiden and there's so many
great solos because there's two amazing
guitarists Dave Murray and Adrien Smith
I mean Dennis Stratton on the the first
album as well yeah sure so Ken says it
would have to be the lead in and final
solos in to tame a land from peace of
mind and now that's an interesting one
because um it's such a long song right
so there's lots and lots of room for
solos in it and it is driven by the
lyrics it's about Dune they actually
wanted to call it Dune but Frank Herbert
wouldn't sign off on that because he
hated heavy metal and so really yeah so
they had to call it to tame a land and
it's um I mean it's I think it's seven
minutes long um so there's there's lots
of room and it's a very um I mean there
is like a a important bridge in it
that you know that section there um but
there's some there's some great solos in
that that's that's really quite true
that's a good one yeah yeah I mean there
it's hard to pick with Maiden right so
you picked
um off the Power Slave album Ryman the
Ancient
Mariner
um and now talk about a long song I
think that one tops off at 14 minutes
and it's also got that that really cool
bass interlude in there as well with the
um with the volume swells yeah exactly
yeah and and then the um um uh Bruce
Dickinson reciting the the poem over
that right um but there are some great
solos like on that whole album but that
I mean Iron Maiden has quite a few long
songs long songs would give you more
more space to
do um an
extended kind of take your time solo
right well there's not I mean there's a
set amount so well I guess let's start
here so the the middle section starting
does and then we pick up with a D D D D
D D D D D and then it starts to grow
yeah and then it kind of goes into this
halftime and then it goes into that Rift
and
man when Adrien Smith comes in with that
first
note with that
vibr now it's kind of bluesy licks but
you can sing it and Adrien Smith has
this grease on his plane the vibr and he
lean a little back into the time right
so he's not like Dave muray is very on
top of the beat right he's almost he's
right on beat and adri a little behind
the beat and
um and you know there's a few surprises
like he'll play like these riffs and
then like he'll skip a beat and then
this notee kind of comes out of nowhere
that's very singable and then at the end
he goes into this like you know kind of
like double time like riff um to like
wrap it up wrap it up and then D and
then it like you know as a nice Cadence
da da like he kind of slows it down
which is a great lead in for the next
solo but I just I mean it's hard to pick
a maiden solo I mean I could have gone
to any album and but Adrien i' I've
always been a huge Adrian Smith's fan
and like I remember watching live after
death and like that was my favorite part
like when Adrian would step up with a
rock and roll you know yeah and and um
with that feel and that vibr and that
tone he's just got it man it's just you
know what you know what a great but like
yeah that Solo's always just got me
because of that it's singable it's his
time it's his little surprise with those
notes getting stuck in there and it and
um yeah I out of all of the maiden I
just picked that one yeah so I I picked
off a Number of the Beast so we got you
know album three four and five here in
our mix um 22 ACAA Avenue another longer
song you know I think it's six six
something long um and there's there's
two big soul solos in the song lots and
lots of great licks but there's two
solos and one is in that slow part of
the song it's very lyrical it's dreamy
there's Reverb on it you know and I I
don't know if it's Murray or Smith who's
playing that one or both you know
alternating um but it's it's just
beautiful you know and then towards the
end of the song once they've picked up
the pace and they've got they've they've
done that don't you know what you're
you're doing you'll see it you to ruin
Charlotte you're taking your life
throwing it
away they lead into that that second
solo and it's just blistering you know
that's Adrian
okay um yeah you're right but it it goes
on um that that solo is it's the outro
to the song and I'd say that solo goes
on for at least 45 seconds maybe a
minute doesn't get boring either see
right yeah yeah I mean he's got ideas
and um a lot of that's what we were
talking about earlier that you know you
know under it too I mean you have Steve
Harris and you know that that amazing
Baseline to it that's got so much energy
you know um I mean that's that's
something you know I I I've always loved
Iron Maiden I'm not as big of a fan of
later work because it doesn't feel like
it has the same sort of energy that
those first six albums have although I
did like Brave New World a lot yeah
yeah I mean I'm not I'm I'm not saying
that they have any like crap albums you
know but um there's you know when you
set the bar that high it's hard to
constantly match it but this also leads
into another interesting
question so when you got two great
guitarists so you know you could think
of Iron Maiden with um uh Dave Murray
and Adrien Smith um I mean when they get
Dennis Stratton wasn't wasn't bad but
he's Adrian Smith you know um and then
you think about Judas Priest with you
know it's original configuration with KK
Downing and uh Glenn Tipton now now
essentially replaced both in concert
stuff um or I mean what would be some
other really I mean you you could say
rat but Robin Crosby was content to sit
back and play Rhythm and let Warren De
Martini take over his lead you know and
he does most of the solos um wasn't he
was really resentful actually that's
interesting because I I've I've read
some interview I think there's like
mixed signals about that oh there's some
interviews where he was like yeah I
recognize the kid you know had more
Talent than me and oh okay yeah but in
any case we can't talk about them being
analogous to no um now interestingly
when rat played live um in the latest
like legitimate configuration of the
band where it was um you know uh waren
de martini with Juan cocher and stevenh
Percy but they had Carlos
cavazo right as the replacement for Ryan
Crosby I think what that did is up the
game you know because cavazo is not just
playing uh rhythm guitar he's also
soloing with um de martini and he's a
legend in the scene from the same era
exactly yeah so he was there kind of
thing you know yeah I mean people talk
about like Thin Lizzy as having a great
two guitar thing and and yeah I mean I
don't consider the metal I consider the
more hard rock um Scott Goram and Brian
Robertson together you know pretty
awesome um but are there any other like
really great classic metal outfits with
two really great both Rhythm and Lead
guitarists that come to mind for you
besides priest and Maiden well they
there should but I would like to say
this the difference between priest and
Maiden is when I was listening to priest
by listening I couldn't tell who was
playing
lead interesting they were very similar
yeah Maiden you knew by the first note
who was playing the lead they were so
different in
style when they played the the the
harmonies you know like you think
loneliness of the longdistance runner
how long and how many sections they
sound great together but they're such
entirely different guitar players with
well when it was Priest I'd hear a solo
and go which guitarist is it and it's
not a put down because I love the
guitarist it's just there are more like
each other God U yeah and I and I think
so I included from sin after sin the
song sinner which is awesome you know
and has some really great guitar soloing
in it and as judah's priest sound
changes what we talked about earlier
from the overdriven to the you know
right distorted sound I think you're
right that KK Downing and Glenn Tipton
they they both changed their sound in
the same way you know right yeah I I I I
agree um yeah I like the earlier ones
like maiden you know it's definitely
Marshall's you know just turned up and
that's it and you know now they've
got they're pretty distorted it's pretty
heavy and I'm always kind of curious
when you see bands that were classic
like why aren't you playing the classic
amps you know um
do you have them you know those are kind
of lame questions I would
ask well let's let's actually uh Veer
off into Mark has a great question that
Ken also has a intering response
interesting response to then we we'll
pick the the other band that both of us
identified um so Mark says question for
all the most overrated solo mine would
have to be Sweet Child Of Mind simply
because it's one of the usual suspects
when guitar Bros want to show off
uh Ken says something really interesting
for me it would be paranoid it's done to
death and I think even Tony would admit
for a guitar solo it's pretty simplistic
now I I don't have a a I think it's
overdone guitar solo um because I don't
like hang out in Guitar Center or
anything like that and listen to all the
uh Bros come in and and you know riff
over one thing but Scott I mean you have
students who are you know trying to show
off their chops is would you say first
of all what do you think of those
two um and then do are there any that
you're like oh man if I don't hear that
again it'll be too
soon I don't know if it's overplaying
like I think the solo to Stairway to
Heaven is of Jame Jimmy Pig's best but I
don't need to hear Stairway to Heaven
again but okay but that solo is one of
my favorite page solos um now Sweet
Child of Mine this is a great one
because because you know we were around
when appetite came out and uh that album
rocked I love the album in the tunes
but um I didn't really think of slashes
like I thought he played the riffs cool
like I love Mr Brownstone I love um uh
Night Train I love that riff and um that
that was rock and roll but the Sweet
Child Of Mind solo and even the Sweet
Child Of Mind lick it was okay you know
yeah and
um and then yeah I can like hear it in
my head right now
that you know it's kind of it's very
musical lyrical you know yeah but I
don't think it's
executed I mean it was fine I mean you
know it was kind of like I didn't I
didn't think of him like a great lead
player I thought like yeah it serves a
tune it's cool let's like get a rock and
roll guitar Soul yeah yeah but let's go
to the present
day somehow he's become the face of rock
Guitar
Gods and I didn't see that coming you
know because when it came out it was
kind of like well this is then you know
the next generation of Joe Perry cool
love Joe Perry love
Aerosmith and for us now for everybody
it's just kind of like slash like you
know believe it or not the young
students at Berkeley don't know much
about rock history but they don't know
who slash is and they know him as kind
of like the rock legend which I don't
know if it's just because I was there
when they came out and it was a great
album but nobody was like slash like
this is the guy you know so yeah I think
the
solo I don't know if I should use the
word overrated but yeah I know exactly
what you're saying because it wasn't
something that I was like I need to
learn this when I heard it I thought
thought cool you know it's time for rock
and roll guitar solo this is cool but
like to say like you know like I'll be
on you know once in a while do like a a
a corporate gig and um they basically
call tunes and I know too many Tunes
they're like you you know Sweet Child of
Mine
yes you know tell your enthusiasm for it
yeah and then but you know I play the
solo pretty much I mean I never sat down
and learned it but I you know yeah hear
it in my head I could play it um and you
know people do go nuts when I play the
solo they go crazy you know and um I'm
like okay well he you know he did
something right I guess you know because
it was it's part of the tune um so
that's that you know overrated solos
yeah I
mean now paranoid is an interesting one
because it is such a short song uh I
want to say
um it's it's three no it's it's 2
minutes and 48 seconds so I was going to
say it's not even three minutes um so
there's not a ton of room in there for
doing much of anything you know it's I
suppose it's probably learned a
lot um and part because it's part of the
the repertoire you know you know this is
you got to remember this is very early
on this is the The Roots You know we we
can argue that they're you
know part of the beginning of
metal right yeah some people say they
were you know um I I I don't want to
point to one band but they are certainly
you know coming up with something and I
would call them the first among equals
you know yeah uh so along with like um
Deep Purple Uriah Heap uh sirl Lord
Baltimore you know but but Black Sabbath
s sits above them and people even say
Zeppelin you know exactly yeah yeah um
but like you know you have to think like
you know the Rifts were amazing
and this was you know if we went back to
those times we might hear it differently
in that I know what you mean but like
you know going back you know pre all the
other stuff you know we might go oh okay
so that's you know that's you know it's
pretty cool let's let's talk about rat
and then we'll each pick one more from
our list so you picked
um uh one off of invasion in your priv
invasion of your privacy not invasion in
your privacy and so did I and it's kind
of funny because you know is is that
their best
album well it's not what they play the
most of in concert I mean what they play
the most of is um out of the seller out
of the seller right yeah invasion of
your privacy usually they'll play two or
three tracks from it and out of the
cellar they'll play not quite half the
album but but a good bit of it but maybe
some of the best solos are actually on
there so you
picked um here it is you're in love
great song right um and it's got that
part I mean the solo is taking place
over a change in the chord progression
right exactly which happens a lot with
them that's true true yeah it's it's so
like the solo is actually part of a
bridge isn't it well it my my second
choice was never use love which does the
same thing yeah yeah um it goes yeah it
goes to yeah it goes to the it actually
goes to kind of the same
chord um it's hard because uh Warren's
one of the greats I think in that era um
the one that I picked lay it down it's
it's a cord progression change too as
well on the r yeah yeah yeah and and I
think I told you um lay it down when I
saw him live in the 80s they brought it
way down to that you know when it goes
down to like yeah yeah and they kept
that going and Warren actually played
for a good five minutes or maybe 10
minutes over just that and it never got
boring he sat there with a cigarette
with the with on him playing some really
nice phrases and he did not run out of
ideas I remember going you know and I
was even back then I oh God like you
know somebody's G get up and do an
unaccompanied solo go Wily Wily Wily
here's my you know yeah so but anyways
um did you want to talk about your uh
well I would pick um motorhead's
Overkill which is or Capricorn off of
Overkill which is probably one of my
favorite Motorhead songs and it's kind
of unusual in that it's it's slower it's
um more
open in its
composition and Eddie Clark um is is he
he's he's so great at like producing
these solos that are just kind of dreamy
you know there's there's a lot of um
like fatness to the sound and a little
bit of Reverb in there and he's he's not
trying to like show off or anything but
he's just producing like this almost
like a web of um notes over what and
like he said he doesn't have a net
beneath him all he's got is lemie and a
drummer and that's it you know so as
opposed to a lot of songs where you can
rely on the other guitarist or a
keyboardist or somebody to like hold
down the Riff right he's got to fill it
all up you know yeah that's I like what
you said at the beginning of um how he
expresses thoughtfully how people have
to sonically find their place yeah you
know and then adjust their
plane somehow it's like Alex sson talks
about when they got keyboards he had to
change his plane entirely to where he
was in the higher register how he had to
come up with different parts and I love
when people talk about I had to find a
way to make this work which means yeah
you know they're in the mind of like you
know then you can say well you know they
put thought into this they didn't just
get together and throw spaghetti at the
wall to see if it would stick you know
yeah I so I really like the story you
told earlier and now that you're talking
about the
solo you know somebody else outside of
the the metal range that um that reminds
me of is Peter hook um he he's a basist
right but he plays a lot in the high
range and um you know he's in
essentially two iterations of a similar
band right let's call it first um I'm
blanking at it um it's new order after
and it's uh Joy Division um oh okay and
the reason why he played those really
high melodic baselines was because he
said that um he had a tiny little amp
and
um the guitarist was playing too loud so
the only way he could actually hear
himself was playing stuff in the high
end so he just sort of made a virtue of
necessity and uh stuck with it and it's
it's part of his signature style and you
know when you see him in concert which
we did here in Milwaukee a couple years
ago he has a basist playing with him and
he uses the bass essentially as a solo
instrument oh see that I was gonna ask
like eventually did you get a did he get
a low end because that might be
missing in that Contex yeah yeah but on
those early songs the Bas is is very
much I mean he does sometimes drop into
the lower strings but he's mostly on
those those two higher strings you know
and pretty high up on the on the
fretboard too you know yeah so perfect
yeah perfect Sonic example so who's who
would you uh pick for the the next one
and then we'll we'll see what what uh
Ken and Mark uh want to say about like
best solos faor
solos God I have so I have a bunch left
but I'm going to pick a I'm going to
pick one that has a totally different
criteria just to get interesting so one
of them I picked was white snake from
the 1987 album of course John Sykes who
who I've always been a huge fan of
crying in the rain now
here's uh now that's
a it's kind of a bombastic
solo and
um so he starts with kind of like this
hanging note and then into the tremol of
picking and then into these hammer on
and then blah blah but if you listen the
band has composed this together right so
um so it kind of starts off with you
know and then it it's kind of like these
hammer on pull-offs and then eventually
you know the drums start coming in and
like playing the
subdivision when he's going B he's doing
like these like hammeron on two strings
and it's kind of like oh I know what
that is but the way the band put it
together was was like this whole thing
and its intensity and there's this one
part of the solo where he just plays for
Four Bars he plays
this singing slow or melodic phrase that
you can sing and it's not out of place
and then he goes back into the intense
thing thing and then uh and then he
builds up on that like you know kind of
two-hand tapping thing or the the pick
skipping thing that goes all the way up
blows up exactly perfectly into the Riff
so we're at the top and I just I it's
one of those where a ton of
notes um and Reckless playing was
exactly what the tune
needed you know that's why I picked that
one you know yeah that's great I I like
that description uh Reckless play
uh sometimes you got to be like leaning
into something to where you know this is
not what you're doing on you know on
guitar but sometimes with physical
movement you need to be like off balance
a bit and moving forward with some
momentum in order to get what you really
need out of and also yeah in like the
you know I remember like it being so
epic and so Arena Rock when I first got
the record I used to put on headphones
and pretend I was in front of a whole
audience playing that solo cuz it had so
much
the and it's not just the band I mean
it's not just syes it's the band if you
listen solo again listen to the bass and
listen to the drums they composed it
they worked it out you know I mean with
Whit snake you have a big band right
you've got drum Bas two guitarists
keyboardist and uh one guitarist when
was there only one at that time okay
because now I think now I think it's
it's so so at that time they were like a
classic
um five piece then right but the tour
had Vivien Campbell and Adrien
vanderberg okay so they did bring two
guitarists there's always two guitarists
on the live tours but on that so that
they can play the Riff uh while the
Solo's going on
right I mean what you see in a lot of um
recordings I mean so we're gonna look at
Sabbath and just a minute great example
is Tony yomi cannot play Rhythm and Lead
at the same time but on a lot of Black
Sabbath recordings just to mention Zero
the Hero he's he's got two tracks that
he's playing he's got his his uh riff
track and then he's got his soloing
track so how do you do that in concert
well you gotta either just not play the
Riff and let the basist handle it um or
you got to have another guitarist
somewhere good point just to interject I
love although it sounds like it was
recorded in a trash can Dawkins beast
from the East I thought you going to
talk about maybe maybe that's the
connection there because born again is
terrible uh production right I mean it's
a great album but oh well this live
album um one guitar and like you know
when he breaks off into his solo you
hear pilson in the drums and I don't
miss the rhythm guitar it's it's like
and he's just going like you could hear
him going for it this young energy and
it's just a cranked Plexi and he's just
you know sometimes he'll like hit it out
of the park and it's just that whole
concert is like you're on the edge of
your seat because it's really raw really
live yeah and you know but you need a
basis like Jeff pilson to pull that off
I mean there there's some basis that can
do that and others that just can't fill
up that that sound you know very good
point so Ken says um this is a great one
sign of the Southern Cross by Black
Sabbath uh from the do era right um so
Tony Omi
had years and years you know to like
perfect his his Craft um Dio revitalized
the band uh Ken says technical melodic
and feeds into Do's singing so yeah I
think that that's quite true I think
that's a good point about uh you know
pointing out Di's vocals and and because
I'm sure Doo's vocals changed how how um
Tony played a little bit you know I
think so yeah like you know when you get
around different musicians you tend to
play differently you know in some
respect you still sound like you but I
mean when you have a musician like doo
who can have all of this stuff sort of
figured out in his head and I would say
like let's say you imagine like you were
getting to play with Steve Harris as
your backup basist right um and it was
just like maybe say well and I know that
you're not as big of a fan of uh nickel
mcbrain so we'll replace him with dead
Clive Burr right yes it'll be you
and those guys no singer just you're
going to play some instrumentals and
stuff like that I mean when Steve Harris
is behind you you can do so much when
when Dio is your singer you can do so
much you know um I don't know that ozy
ever I mean A's an okay singer chops
wise um and he's definitely Black
Sabbath's you know first singer I don't
know that you can say that he and Tony
yomi um have the kind of
Mutual connection that that Dio and yomi
had on those those two early albums and
then their their Later
album yeah um yeah that's I would agree
yeah it always you know in in a
situation like one of the things if I
were
to you know let's say where I I were to
be in Maiden for a while um the first
thing I'd have to do is find out where
the time laid in the Rhythm Section yeah
yeah you know because with each Rhythm
Section you know like when you play
together for a long time that's like
everybody's feel kind of like locks and
gels so the first thing is the Big
Challenge when you step into a Rhythm
Section that's you know spent decades
getting there where they place the beat
is finding out where that is so you lay
in there correctly on everything the
Rhythm Parts it's not just playing the
parts it's finding the time with where
it's laid I mean um like feeling it it's
one thing here in the records it's
another thing having it surround you
while you're physically playing with
them
so but yeah yeah and you know I mean
this is a bit of a digression and we we
we're gonna have to close up pretty soon
um but I was just thinking about Ian
Hill you know he doesn't get the sort of
like stature that um Steve Harris does
as a basist and Steve Harris is just a
God you know when it comes to to base
there's almost nobody who can compare to
him U but Ian hill is pretty am good and
he has been there from the very
beginning I think that he's really the
core of the band and I I I wonder when
you have somebody who's been there that
long or in Black Sabbath Tony yomi is
the core of the band Geer Butler
arguably you know the second part of
that um and they like you said they've
been doing this for decades getting to
like come in and play with them um it's
like going
into a well-oiled machine proverbial
speaking that has been happening and
doing the same thing for years and years
and years at a very high level um I
think that would you know it would be
sort of a make or break moment right
either you measure up to it or you can't
fit in and then you know what does that
say about you you're given this amazing
opportunity to play with these really
great players or imagine if you could
have you know play in a band and you had
John Lord on the Oregon you know I mean
a lot of it is uh that's why All-Star
bands don't always work oh yeah because
they don't go well together yeah yeah I
always say like it's you know people
that are into soccer Brazil has the
greatest players in the world but you
know they don't always really win games
you know because the team itself isn't
those other teams even though they have
the better players you know but yeah
well we should we should wrap this up um
thanks so much to to Ken and Mark for
some great comments and as always thank
you yeah and uh next time we are gonna
be interviewing Ken actually about one
of those I was there type of moments uh
pertaining to the new wave of British
heavy metal Scott and I could only kind
of witness it from the other side of the
pond living out in the sticks getting to
see stuff in magazines and and uh
listening to you know import
albums we missed a lot of what was
actually happening so I'm really looking
forward to getting to chat about about
that I think it'll probably be quite
Illuminating um anything you want to say
Scott to close us
out um yeah I just yeah this was a great
kind of exercise and um and uh I'm I
hope you know I invited a lot of people
but you know I hope to share this with
students oh yeah because this whole
notion of you can have an opinion but
being able to express it um I think that
was really kind of like we didn't say
these are the 10 best guitar solos of
all time we just picked out things that
we solos that we really loved and to the
big pieces explain why we like solo and
um and and you know in just discussing
it a lot of different things came up as
they always do um it it doesn't really
stick to script alog together we come up
with new ideas and kind of like new
thoughts and new challenges what do you
think of this oh that's a good point you
know so yeah I as usual a great
discussion and um I always look forward
to doing these so that's that's it for
me